voilà volodymyr zelensky qui vient de
terminer son intervention devant le
congrès américain il a obtenu tant
d'innovations beaucoup d'émotion
juste avant son discours qui a duré une
quinzaine de minutes le destin notre
pays est en train de s'écrire c'est une
attaque contre notre désir de bonheur
contre notre démocratie at il dit et
puis il rappelle il réitère son appel à
une zone d'exclusion aérienne au dessus
de l'ukraine il dit au congrès américain
qu'ils ont besoin d'avions de systèmes
de défense aérienne à défaut de zone
d'exclusion aérienne parce que cette
exclusion aérienne virgin hier sera
difficile voire impossible à mettre en
place ça équivaut à la troisième guerre
mondiale avait dit joe biden oui
absolument et d'ailleurs cet appel à une
zone d'exclusion aérienne
en fait il l'a dit vraiment quasiment
sans conviction plus il l'a dit pour le
dire mais en fait tu l'appelles précis
et concrets ce qui le demande
d'obtenir aujourd'hui c'est des
sanctions jusqu'à ce que la machine de
guerre russes s'arrête des sanctions
envers tous les responsables politiques
du régime russe qui ne démissionne pas
c'est ça que demandent aujourd'hui
volodymyr zelensky sachant que
militairement les états unis et l'otan
ne vont pas s'engager au delà on sait
qu'il avait fait déjà depuis longtemps
une demande de zone d'exclusion aérienne
vous l'avait dit et ça a été refusé il
ya eu aussi toute cette question sur les
sur les avions des mig qui pouvait être
transféré depuis la pologne finalement
les polonais ne voulaient pas les
envoyer directement sur le sol ukrainien
craignant d'être entraînés dans la
guerre ça pouvait partir depuis la base
aérienne de ramstein en allemagne les
etats-unis ont dit non et là dessus je
pense que ça ne bougera certainement pas
donc maintenant les aides qui a cédé
aide de
dz militaires d'armements qui sont en
cours qui ont été une grosse enveloppe a
été débloquée par par le par le congrès
et l'autre aide c'est vraiment de faire
pression maximum sur c'est sûr les
dirigeants russe vladimir poutine et
tout son entourage volodymyr zelensky a
demandé que soit fermé la porte à tous
les produits russes c'est à dire
véritablement il appelle un véritable
embargo quasiment un mot elena sur cette
zone d'exclusion aérienne que refuseront
les occidentaux à commencer par joe
biden on entendra à son intervention un
peu plus tard dans l'après midi mais
c'est vrai que la menace pour les
ukrainiens elle vient pour l'instant du
ciel oui complètement est ce que
demandent aujourd'hui pour le dîner les
skis c'est tout simplement de ne pas le
laisser seul et de l'aider à défendre
son pays à défendre l'ukraine il l'a
clairement dit selon lui les l'aide des
occidentaux est insuffisante il a bien
conscience effectivement qu'il
n'obtiendra pas cette zone d'exclusion
aérienne donc là ce qu'ils demandent
c'est une demande à minima c'est à dire
si j'ai bien compris de lui fournir des
systèmes de défense antiaériens parce
que les premières cibles de l'aviation
russe et des bombardements russes ont
été les systèmes de défense antiaériens
une craignant les postes de commandement
et c'est donc en fait même s'ils n'ont
pas été complètement détruits mais les
capacités de défense de l'ukraine sont
aujourd'hui largement amoindrie et ce
que dit en somme vous le dit mr hélène
ce qui dans ce discours devant le
congrès aujourd'hui c'est si vous ne
nous aidez pas au moins en nous livrant
davantage d'armes davantage de systèmes
pour nous défendre et bien tout
simplement mon pays sera détruit il
appelle aussi à lies création d'une
association d'une alliance de pays
responsable pour la paix c'est très
vague oui alors ça ça peut paraître un
peu surprenant effectivement il a dit
que le système les organisations
internationales qui ont été créés après
la deuxième guerre mondiale pour
préserver la paix se sont révélées être
inopérant tous et toujours les problèmes
de blocage au niveau du conseil de
sécurité est dit il faut créer une
alliance pour la paix en fait ça fait un
peu finalement écho aux références à
l'alliance et le sommet pour la
démocratie qu'avait lancé joe biden vous
rappelez peut-être il en avait parlé
avant d'être élu et finalement joe biden
a lancé cette idée de pays occidentaux
et au delà de grandes démocraties du
monde qui ont un intérêt et des valeurs
communes à défendre face à des à des
régimes et à des gouvernements
autocratiques qui était en train en
train de se développer donc c'est
certainement en référence à ça mais
c'était plus un appel politique plus
globale plutôt qu'une demande une
demande concrète voilà donc les
américains